Hello Freak bitches. Um, you know,
just to flip to the other end of the
spectrum in terms of what like coevolution
between two different species to
be like over the last 20,000 years.
Look at what we've done.
We've taken wolves and you've
turned them into these creatures.
We put Halloween costumes on and
like a finding a couple of years ago,
which floored me.
This hormone oxytocin,
which is totally trendy.
Oxytocin is completely cool.
Mother infant bonding is mediated by
oxytocin pair bonding in monogamous
species.
Oxytocin makes you more trusting and
expressive and generous and economic games
and oxytocin has all these pro
social effects within a species.
Then it turns out that this hormone
that has spent the last, I dunno,
a hundred million years,
having mothers and infants connect
to each other emotionally. Um,
when you and your beloved dog sit
there and stare into each other's eyes,
you both secrete oxytocin.
And if you pump up oxytocin
levels and your dog,
it will stare at you longer and you will
stare longer back, be more oxytocin.
This is like an ancient, ancient hormone
having to do with mother infant bonding.
And in 20,000 years, which is like
a blink of an eye evolutionarily.
Suddenly we're doing this weird oxytocin
tango thing with another species,
another species who we feed and take care
of and they like manipulate as wildly
and to like get him like good dessert,
treat bones and stuff like that and they
in turn do all sorts of one for stuff
for our self esteem because they
like lick us unconditionally.
Where'd that come from?
I just 20,000 years and you've like hijack
this ancient neuroendocrinology about
like parental behavior and now it's got
to do with this weird symbiotic thing.
We end wolf was worked
out somewhere back on him.
What does it have any
effect on friendship?
Like a human being staring at each other?
Did that, does anybody ever tested that?
I would assume people have looked at that.
It,
for example,
it strengthens monogamous bonds and
there's a literature by now looking at
oxytocin has its effects by
binding to an oxytocin receptor.
There's a gene for the oxytocin receptor.
It comes at a number of variants and if
you have one particular variant that's
associated with Oxytocin,
having less effective women move in your
nervous system that's associated with
less stable relationships.
Uh, so you know,
none of this stuff is
deterministic. Your, your,
your sex life and your romantic life has
not been determined by this one gene.
Like nothing remotely resembling,
but that's just part of the mix.
And there I was just wonder if that makes,
applies to like platonic friendships,
like male bonding and stuff.
I wonder if there's like when
guys are out having a good time,
if they're also getting a good
juice of oxytocin. Might guesses.
When you have your,
your basic like pathetic male sociality,
it's just like you've like talk about
sports for five minutes with some guy and
as a result, you're willing to give up
your life for him because like, you know,
this is male, male body. I bet that's
got something to do with oxytocin.
Okay.